MARTIN OMANDER:
Today, I'm joined
by Waleed Abdulla,
founder of Ninua.
Good to see you here, Waleed.
WALEED ABDULLA:
Thank you, Martin.
MARTIN OMANDER: So you were
here for the last episode.
For viewers who didn't
watch the last episode,
would you give a
brief description
of what Ninua,
your startup, does?
WALEED ABDULLA: Sure.
So we have two products--
Symphony at symphonytools.com,
which is a social media
dashboard for businesses
to publish to a lot of social
networks at the same time
and to listen to what their
customers are saying about them
on the social networks.
And the second is
NetworkedBlogs,
which is a platform for
bloggers to promote their blog
and network with other bloggers.
We have about 1.2
million bloggers on it.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
So on the last
episode, we talked
about how you changed
business models,
and this changing
of business model
meant that you needed to go
after a different customer
segment and have a
slightly different product.
WALEED ABDULLA: Mhm.
MARTIN OMANDER: Now, this is
a situation a lot of startups
face all the time-- that
we need new features to go
after a new customer segment.
How did you validate
that you were building
the right features that these
customers needed and liked?
WALEED ABDULLA: So
basically, we had
a few insights from
our existing product,
things that we noticed as we
interacted with our users.
And then we took
that, and then we
want to decided what to do next.
We kind of knew we had to
do something different.
And we had an idea
what that might be,
but there was a lot
of details and a lot
of possible directions to take.
So we took about
a month to create
about 25 different
business plans.
For each one, we would
say, what if we do this,
and we go after this market?
How will that play out?
What are the options for
finding customers, monetizing
the product?
What are the options for
getting funding, and so on.
We created 25 of those, and
then we selected the best.
So that was the first step.
And then after that, we
started building a product.
And once we had a
version that was,
let's say, an alpha
version, barely works,
we started showing
it to people, and we
started collecting
feedback that way.
We showed it to lot of people--
from friends to random people
to other potential customers.
We collected a lot
of feedback and kind
of modified the
vision accordingly.
MARTIN OMANDER: And you had
a pretty structured approach
of how you did
this user testing.
Could you tell us a
bit more about that?
WALEED ABDULLA: Right, so
once we started showing it
to people, the first step
was, show it to your friends.
So we have a lot of friends,
and we just kind of bug them
and say, hey, can you take
a look at this product
and tell us what you think?
So that was the first phase.
And we collected a lot of
data and we modified it.
Once we felt comfortable
with the overall feature set,
we went to the next step, which
was to show it to real users.
So we had recruited users
to take a look at it.
And we'll do a screen-sharing
session with them
for about an hour.
We send them the link.
They take a look at the product,
and they start using it.
And we'll just sit
there and watch
what they do and take notes.
MARTIN OMANDER: So you're
watching what they do.
Did you have them
come into your office,
or did you do it remotely?
How did these sessions work?
WALEED ABDULLA: When we
started with friends,
we'll just sit next to them.
But when we started doing
it with other users,
we will do a Skype
screen-sharing session.
So they will share their
screen, and then we
send them the link
right before the call
so they don't look at
it before the call.
And we send it to
them, and we just
ask them to behave as
if we're not there,
and explore the product
and speak their mind.
So they would say,
I'm confused now.
I don't know what to do.
Should I click here?
Should I click there?
And we just listen, and we
don't give them any hints.
We just kind of take notes
that the user was confused
at this point, the user
was excited at this point,
and so on.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
And so now, you're getting
all these great feedback.
How do you integrate that
with your project development?
WALEED ABDULLA: Yeah, so
we did this for 60 days.
We would have one
call every day.
And we'll take
notes, and then we'll
modify the application
that same day.
MARTIN OMANDER: That same day?
WALEED ABDULLA: That same day.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, wow.
WALEED ABDULLA: And then we'll
have a different user next day
to take a look.
And then we know
whether our changes
worked, or is the user still
confused about this feature,
and so on.
So we kept doing that
for two full months
until we felt very
comfortable and we
started getting really
good feedback from users.
MARTIN OMANDER: So
you had lots and lots
of little very, very tight
feedback cycles it sounds like.
WALEED ABDULLA: Yes,
so at that point,
we were trying to validate that
the product is well-designed,
it's easy to understand,
and that people
cared about the features.
So we would have
sometimes just fake menus,
and we'll see if someone
would even click on them.
And that will tell
us if someone's
interested in that thing.
And we will have different
names for the actions,
different names for the
menus, different colors.
And basically, we're testing how
easy and intuitive the app is,
and whether people
can just use it
without someone helping them.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, great.
You must have made a lot of
changes over those two months.
WALEED ABDULLA: Yes, yes.
It saved us a lot
of time in features
that we learned that
they were not important.
We had a lot of
features, like we
thought maybe analytics
will be important.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, really?
Great.
One would think that, yeah?
WALEED ABDULLA: Yeah.
And we realized that,
OK, very few of our users
actually cared.
So we decided, OK, let's
not build that right away.
And then that helped us
launch the product sooner.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, great.
What were some of the
other things you liked,
on the other side--
things that people
liked that you hadn't expected?
WALEED ABDULLA: We
had an option to share
your articles to
social networks.
And we have two different
ways of doing it.
So one of them, we
called it crosspost
and the other one was share.
And there was a little
bit of excitement
when people see the
word "crosspost."
And they would say, oh,
I know what that does.
And they immediately
assumed it takes your post
and crossposts it
all over the place.
And so we though, OK, that
kind of was interesting.
And we started getting the
same feedback every day.
So we start making that feature
more and more prominent,
and we started improving it.
And then now, it's actually one
of the most important features
in the product, which is
something we discovered
through these tests that we
wouldn't have known otherwise.
MARTIN OMANDER: Otherwise, it
wouldn't have happened, right.
WALEED ABDULLA: Probably.
MARTIN OMANDER: And it sounds
like it's a feature that you
might have built, but
through user testing,
you discovered
that was important,
and how to position
it and name it.
WALEED ABDULLA:
Exactly, exactly.
And that's very
important, especially
when you're getting the
user seeing your product
the first time, the
first impression.
You want the application
to be easy to understand,
and you want to
make it intuitive so
that they don't get
frustrated and having
to ask you a lot of
questions about it.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
Well, thank you very much
for sharing your experiences
with us, Waleed.
WALEED ABDULLA:
Sure, you're welcome.
MARTIN OMANDER: Hope
you found something
useful for your startup here.
If you have comments
on the show,
please leave them in the
YouTube comment field.
We read everything you write.
Finally, if you
are in a startup,
go to
developers.google/com/startups,
and find out how
Google can help you.
See you next time.